the following trailer is rated s for
spoilers presented by movies anywhere
your movies together at last download
the movies anywhere app today and bring
your movie collection together
[Music]
you love Pokemon and Ryan Reynolds you
definitely hate video game movies and
you probably don't have a hot take on
film noir now legendary will mush it all
together and hope something clicks in
Pokemon detective Pikachu
get ready polka fans after 21 animated
movies 22 seasons of TV and countless
video games Pokemon is finally getting a
live action film based on the weird
spin-off that no one bought outside
Japan I'm sorry but can we investigate
your closely but a mystery game for
six-year-olds was probably the right
choice to adapt since every other polka
thing is a dogfighting simulator pay2win
card game or a playable corpse finder
what see all of your favorite Pokemon
come to life on the big screen like
Charizard the tongue one or what is that
thing but for those who don't know or
care grab a hold of Ryan Reynolds
Pikachu I will electrocute you a
detective who's wisecracking charm could
carry a premise as dumb as well
detective Pikachu because no matter how
you feel about Pokemon this is the
closest we'll get to a new Deadpool for
a while and I mean come on just look at
the little guy oh wait was I saying
yeah movies alright I mean he's a
Pikachu's a detective you get what you
pay for
when you need someone to act scared of
an animated lizard you call justice
Smith
unravel the mystery of his missing dad
who spoiler alert is the character who
sounds exactly like his dad that's a
twist
that's dopinder could have cracked this
in like five seconds but with the help
of this girl from a completely different
movie but I don't fear fear I walk the
walk and I talk the talk and I'm willing
to do whatever it takes to get the
honest scoop and that's the hard truth
they'll uncover a businessman secret
plot to merge humans and pokémon because
movie I mean I get why he would want a
polka body but why would he bother to
make all of humanity oh there's my furry
widow guy who's my pika pika you don't
have to make any sense at all do you
know you know franchise known for
fighting get only the tiniest glimpse of
its potential then thrill at action
set-pieces where our heroes run away
from a pokemon run away from a pokemon
run away from a pokemon run away from
this forest that's actually a pokemon
and run away from hey not for the games
say it just say it
Pokemon so get ready for a film that was
a bit too dark for kids are you gonna
make me into a lampshade and a bit too
cutesy for adults but nonetheless takes
its rightful place as the third best
hard-boiled detective story featuring
cartoon animals ever suck at cool world
starring just as for Smith little yellow
different April O'Neil coward the dark
ah sad lieutenant would have called
rhyme City honestly this cats trailer
doesn't look so bad gas monkey donkey
monkey Joker did it and when you need a
British stage actor to class up
disposable pop culture you call Bill
Nighy
Who Framed Ryan Reynolds so for the
sequel how are they gonna get Ryan
Reynolds back inside the Pikachu or is
it gonna be the other way around this
episode was brought to you by movies
anywhere you choose where to purchase
your favorite movies we'll bring them
together in one place movies anywhere
download the app today rubber baby buggy
bumpers Leslie I tucked her symptoms
into the Internet and it says you could
have network connectivity problems